with the uplifted quest we're looking  for our three photographers to capture  images that define what it means to  uplift humanity  that moment of connection with others  and the world around them  what this is all about is mazda national  geographic partnering together  to tell stories of inspiration so cool  at mazda inspiration is central to what  we hold dear  ready to go do this this for me really  is about the  emotional connection that you make  between the people that you photograph  what's inspiring you to click that  shutter  as a mom to a special needs kid like it  just really  yeah it was really really incredible the  challenge is to capture that emotion  so we can be inspired as well if you can  capture how we feel  every day then i think you're in the  right place doing great  the x factor in photography is often  about that moment  that reveals how humans have the power  to uplift and be uplifted  that's what the challenge is all about  it's pretty sweet